why do you think Bitcoin mining is so
disruptive and Innovative specifically
for the oil and gas industry I think a
lot of people think of Bitcoin uh store
value they think of it as a medium of
exchange to think of it as a speculation
tool in financial markets but you're
specifically talking about this
intersection of Bitcoin mining and oil
and gas being such that this like match
made in heaven why is that and so really
what Bitcoin mining is is a lot of
things but it's the democratization of
energy Innovation so if you wanted to
innovate in the power sector or an
energy business
you needed to be independently wealthy
with billions of dollars or you needed
to work in a massive Corporation you're
going to work at that company for 10 20
years and you know once you control the
purse strings you know you're probably
not going to innovate near as much so
what Bitcoin mining did is it you
leveraged several principles which is
you know bottom up Solutions and skin in
the game permissionless Innovation so
anybody globally now can be an energy
entrepreneur I mean literally you can
have you know there are no barriers to
entry you can rub two nickels and if you
can plug in an Asic you can innovate so
we are all thrown out I mean I remember
three years ago we were like okay what's
some of the best from a first principles
standpoint what's the lowest cost energy
okay it's waves okay well the biggest
most consistent waves are in the middle
of nowhere Sweet let's take the Bitcoin
mining there and then really there's all
these engineering and this is what we
were studying five years ago was there's
these engineering technologies that are
in the energy or Energy Technologies but
they're they're engineering successes
but they're not economic successes and
so what Bitcoin mining does is it gives
anybody a line of sight to profitability
and so really like I like this the App
Store you know before the app store if
you want to innovate in software you
need to work at a big oligopoly or get
back by VC or something like that what
the App Store did was it gave it
democratized innovation in the software
business so all of a sudden you had a
clear line of sight to profitability uh
if you could innovate and so the same
thing with the Naka motor of it
basically just sent a private you know a
signal to the market and said if you
lower the cost of power then we will
give you more capital and so really
Bitcoin mining is the most beautifully
Savage Venture Capital company and it's
focused on one thing and one thing only
if you lower the price of power you get
more Bitcoin you get more resources in
your success and so we're going to see
this iterative process play out for the
next Century usher in a Carter Chef type
1 Society but really you've democratized
it
Bitcoin is a venture capital fund it's
not something most people have thought
about explain that further yeah so this
idea was popularized by a guy named
Jesse Pelton who worked on Hollow ranch
with me on the um it really was one of
the pioneers of demand response in Texas
uh so yeah basically you know Venture
Capital looks at what are disruptive
things and then how do we give capital
and make asymmetric bets and you know
you there is you know everyone wants to
go it's an efficient market it's not you
got to know people you gotta have the
networks so there's all these people
that have been disenfranchised because
they didn't go to the you know High
pedigree schools and so what Bitcoin
mine does is it strips out all emotions
all relationships the only thing that
matters is if you lower the price of
power then you get to you you spend less
on your operating expenses go down which
means your profit margin goes up which
you get more capital from the Bitcoin
Network through the you know the
algorithm that releases blocks every 10
minutes so you get more resources and so
if you know you have a over here they
can get power to five cents and B over
here which innovates and gets Powers
down to two cents well B is going to get
more profit and has you know more
resources and then we'll redeploy that
and so I think you know this is this is
very early but you're seeing it all of
us and now we've got this great I can
literally get on my phone and I
unfortunately do this too much oh well
that's a great idea who are the experts
like we were looking at wave stuff three
years ago oh they're all like in Europe
in London okay great and I literally got
on with three of the world's experts on
Wave turbines just like that so I think
not only do you have liquidity in the
capital markets with Bitcoin now you
don't need to have cool relationships
Communications and so I can hop on and
find experts on any idea and then you
know throw [__] against the wall and see
what sticks you mentioned that Bitcoin
will have an impact on civilization as
well describe what do you mean there how
much time do you have I think I think it
you know I talk about Bitcoin point and
two Frameworks one it's an energy
Revolution
and two it's a human Freedom Revolution
and so if you live we have the greatest
Financial uh markets in America full
stop and because of that mass there's a
high amount of trust so the higher trust
can be the more value that's created
there's a company called trust Ventures
they that's like literally their concept
thank you Brian and Sal
um but really if you can Elevate trust
so but globally we that doesn't exist
you know and so like you know Nigeria
Venezuela you hear about these places
they don't have trust in their financial
systems and they can't save so if you
and now with the lightning Network and
other Innovations on bitcoin you know if
you wanted to savings is very critical
to elevating your family out of abject
poverty but if you're living in an
inflationary environment that's
impossible to do because you're always
trying to trying to saving is easy
investing is hard and so really what you
just did is you democratize savings with
Bitcoin so anybody can stack SATs
anybody all you need is a cell phone and
cell phones are super cheap thanks to
Innovation and so really you've got all
these disenfranchised
developing nations with individuals
globally who now have an opportunity to
save and knowing that their the value
they're saving cannot be printed away
and so I think this is going to play out
over the coming centuries where you know
America is the land of the free
and it was created by dissidents who
left the old world and I I think there
is mass amounts of dissonance globally
and now you've given them the greatest
human savings technology you know
anti-fragile technology I mean nobody
can shut it down so I think this is
going to play out and equip families and
individuals
um who and I think that's the beauty of
and need for education and in the market
of like Bitcoin unless you're like a Ron
Paul audit the FED person here in
America Bitcoin is is difficult to grasp
but like that was one of the greatest
things I want a few of us were invited
to the human rights uh Freedom Forum in
Ozil a few years ago and I'd hosted
dinners with my American friends I'd
hosted all these events trying to bring
education and Alex Gladstone orange
killed a lot of people at some of the
events I'd host but but it was always
like yeah but I don't need it was always
a brick wall but when I went to the Oslo
freedom for him and I was like oh hey
here's what Bitcoin does they're like
okay great how do I get that like they
wanted it they need it so Innovation
happens on The Fringe so I think that's
where you know the lightning Network and
everything that's happening The
Innovation isn't going to happen in
America
um exclusively it's gonna happen where
the people need it most and when you
think about
20 30 50 years from now what does that
look like in the world is it
running on a Bitcoin standard and it's
like hyper bitcoinization is it Bitcoin
is a savings technology and people still
have other assets that they're investing
in like how do you think about it full
well-knowing predicting 50 years out is
nearly impossible yeah and so I I I I
have an opinion on the energy side but
but on the just broad Bitcoin is not
just the money you know and I'll use the
analogy when people came to America
um why why did America become so
powerful why was so much wealth created
here and I think you tie back to
property rights so when people came to
America they could own land and the
founding fathers could never have
conceptualized you know apps and social
media so how do we get well really we
had land and on top of land which is
like the base layer of Bitcoin people
built farming people built
shops built real estate but then they
built an LLC a corporation like these
are those are layer one two three on you
know of land and so none of that was
possible and then the internet comes
along and supercharged it so when I
think about the future of Bitcoin to me
it's an elevation of the principles that
made America great and so it is taking
you know the United States Constitution
and enshrining it into code to where it
set a vision and it you know it gives
more clarity and confidence to if you
create value and because ecosystem it'll
be mutually beneficial so I think
there's a lot of fascinating that
bitcoin's going to intertwine with all
our lives in ways that we can't really
conceptualize but you know we'll be able
to run things in a decentralized manner
um you know on Layer Two and I'm even
hearing about layer three that just way
over my skis